after over a year of rumors and leaks
apple finally announced their ear tags
at their spring event
and they had a few surprises that we
weren't expecting which we'll talk about
we'll also compare air attacks to their
biggest competitor
tile which just have three major
advantages and if you should upgrade to
air tags if you already own those
with that we'll talk about if tile will
survive
or end up going bankrupt and the lawsuit
that they started
against apple tile has been around for
years now and they've really
made this category popular and because
of that they have four different
trackers on the market
the mate the slim the sticker and the
pro
the two smallest trackers have no
replaceable batteries and have the least
range but they are waterproof since
they're sealed and the slim is basically
a credit card for your wallet
which apple can't compete in size since
it's more than twice as thick
but they are by far the weakest in
performance i'll be focusing on the pro
which is the closest in performance and
just slightly thicker
larger and heavier than apple's air tag
but the first advantage is that it
includes a hole
so you don't need to use a holder if you
want to attach it to your keychain
or to the outside of a bag and that can
make it much more convenient cost wise
the pro costs five dollars more if
you're just buying a single tracker
but if you buy a four pack then it costs
the same as buying four air tags at 99
and with that you don't have to go spend
more for a holder which apple offers
from 29 up to 39 each or say belkins for
13
and you also have third party ones like
a four pack for just over 10 bucks
but either way that is adding extra cost
and of course
extra bulk as well so they're no longer
be smaller now that doesn't tell the
whole story since tile
also has an optional subscription
service to get your full features
which we'll talk about in just a bit
both use the same cr2032 batteries and
are rated for one year of battery life
and both use the same bluetooth low
energy protocol to ping the trackers
but air tags has a major advantage with
the accelerometer and the extra u1 chip
which allows those with iphone 11s or
newer to use spatial
awareness to precisely find the ear tag
with your phone
literally guiding you to your object
using a mix of ar kit
accelerometer and gyroscope as a guide
to the air tag
with a combination of sound haptics and
even visual feedback now tile will show
you the location of your tracker but it
is similar to apple's fine mind for
airpods or other devices
so it is nowhere near as precise as
actually guiding you right to your
tracker
both have a speaker to chime you to the
location but of course
if an item is buried deep in cushions
the speaker will be muted
now tile says that the pro is their
loudest tracker
and i'm sure that the air tag won't be
quiet but if i had to guess
i would think that tile would be louder
because it is thicker
and not completely waterproof like the
air tag but we will see
once we get our hands on the air tags in
just a few days so go ahead and click
down on the subscribe button if you guys
want to see a hands-on comparison
and to help us reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of the year
now tile does have one really cool
exclusive feature
that air tags don't and that is the
built-in button which can be pressed to
find your iphone
forcing it to play a sound even if it's
in silent mode which could be
very convenient as far as range the tile
pro can stay connected up to 400 feet
away
which is the best in the market and
double that of the cheaper tile mate
now apple didn't mention what the range
is but on the site they have a photo
showing an iphone tracking
multiple air tags in different locations
and each one is listed at 0.1 miles away
which is 528 feet now i'm not sure if
that is going to be the official rating
but it is definitely possible since the
protocol officially supports up to 800
feet
in line of sight either way i don't
think it'll be any worse than tiles 400
feet
tile pro is splash resistant but air
tags are actually
waterproof with an ip67 rating so they
could be completely submerged at one
meter for 30 minutes
so there will be no worries about water
dust or moisture
with that air tag has one more chip
inside of it
and that is nfc so you can just bring
your phone close or tap it
and you'll get a pop-up to name it and
you're done so it's extremely quick and
easy to set up
with tile you need to download the app
and then go through a series of steps to
choose the tile that you have
scan it with bluetooth and then connect
to it and then finish
up with the setup so it's not as easy
along with that ear tags can use the nfc
chip
to tell somebody that has found your
item who it belongs to which is great
and that could be done without needing
an app which tile can't do either
and you don't even need to own an iphone
since nfc works with android phones as
well
another exclusive to apple's air tag is
a warning to iphone users if somebody
has placed an air tag on you to try to
track you
at first it will give you a pop-up on
your iphone and then after that
after a while it will start to beep as
well if the owner doesn't put that air
tag into lost mode
now this doesn't really help you as an
owner but it does really help with
people's privacy
and apple really seems to care about
privacy
since no data is ever stored on the air
tag and everything is
anonymous and encrypted every step of
the way so not even
apple knows the location of your air tag
or the identity of the device that helps
find it
and this is probably the biggest
difference actually finding objects that
were lost or stolen
when they are far away from you tile
says that they have sold over 30 million
trackers and that the network
is used if you lose your item and once
it is pinged by a tile
user you will get an updated location
notification on your phone
air tags work the same way but we have
two massive differences
there are over 1.6 billion iphones sold
and apple is coding hundreds of millions
of users that are part of the network
that will also include ipads and macs as
well
not only iphones and the real kicker is
that you don't need to have the app
installed
and enabled and you don't even need to
own any air tags for you to be part of
the network
it is all done automatically and apple
says that is done without any privacy or
data issues with tile out of those 30
million sold
some people may not be using them
anymore or the battery dies since the
older ones only lasted a year without
replaceable batteries
or if you don't have the app installed
or maybe even enabled
that tracking also will not work so the
chances if you find your item is
much much better with air tags and
faster as well
and then comes the issue of
subscriptions if you want to have a
history of where your tile has been
or you want to share the location with
family or even get smart notifications
say if you
left something behind you have to pay an
additional three dollars a month for
that
where with air tags there is no extra
subscription charge
now we don't know if some of these
features will be available but most
people think that they will
since the air tag can actually ping
other people when they're with them
and along with that because find my can
already be set up for family use
apple doesn't need to charge an extra
subscription fee
because apple is making money on keeping
you in their ecosystem
making it hard for you to get rid of
your iphone and switch to android or for
something else
they don't have to be making money from
these air tags themselves
and that is where the last advantage of
tile comes in
the fact that you can use it both with
ios
and android so if you have both devices
you won't just be limited to ios
and if you don't want to be stuck in
apple's ecosystem
that will keep you having some
flexibility if you want to get an
android device
later but if you are already committed
to apple's ecosystem air tags will
definitely be quicker
and more convenient to use so single air
tags cost
less than tile the network is way way
bigger
there's no subscription cost for the
full features they are easier to use and
set up and they do a much better job
helping you find your stuff
yes there are a few downsides but the
upsides make air tags a clear winner for
most people
so if you're an apple's ecosystem i
would highly recommend buying the air
tags over tile
and if you already own tile trackers
there are many reasons that you might
want to upgrade
now i honestly think that they will end
up being extremely popular
or you can even say viral because the
price is reasonably low and there's no
monthly charge
and they are just so easy to use that
anybody can use them even non-techie
people like say
most grandparents i personally would be
buying multiple sets and putting one
on my boat in my car on my bike with
important bags
and more than that because this is by
far the cheapest and easiest insurance
policy
if you want to call it you know an
insurance policy and with that if you
are an ios user i think you should
definitely buy at least
a couple of these now because of this
there's a chance that tile will have a
hard time surviving
apple entering the smart tracking space
and they know it as well
as soon as there were rumors of air tags
tile filed an anti-trust
suit against apple in the us and then
later in europe as well saying that
find my is installed with iphone setup
and they can't be deleted
while tile is a separate app it has to
be installed and it also can be deleted
and it has to go through more privacy
loops than apple does
and of course all of that is completely
true honestly i think tile just knows
how hard it will be for them to compete
and as a result of the suit apple opened
up the fine mind to other companies
that may want to work with them through
their mfi program
with their own trackers i think that for
tile to survive
they need to connect with android to be
integrated into that system
or at least a few major companies and
possibly
cave and use apple's mfi program for
find my which means they will have to
pay apple some royalties
but that will add a lot of convenience
and access to a much much bigger network
they might also have to drop their
subscription plan but that means a loss
of sales
so they are in a really really tough
spot go ahead and let me know what you
think of all of this down in the comment
section below and which one you prefer
and if you are already a tile owner will
you be switching to air tags
go ahead and click that circle above to
subscribe and help us reach our goal of
1 million subscribers before the end of
this year this has been max and i will
catch you
in the next video
you